to give you an idea of
um what went down here with the story
this is a lawyer's article russell
alexander's a family collaborative
lawyer so he took all the information
distilled it down in a summary
and you'll see where this guy went wrong
and
i'll definitely hook you up with the
details um hang on let me grab this
super chat here this
uh sans pure thanks for this is off
topic where's your amazon book list link
uh it's pinned in the description um
also if you're following me
on social media there's a link tree link
there now for like twitter and uh
instagram and stuff like that click that
and it opens up and you'll see the
amazon recommended books there but
thanks for the super chat all right so
russell here distills this for you guys
and says and yet another ontario case
that offers a glimpse into the lifestyle
of the mega rich
the recent decision in clemens versus
latner
so this is her lisa versus michael
allow the court to examine the contours
of what constitutes common-law spouse
under ontario family law act ontario for
those of you that don't that don't know
we don't have states in canada we have
provinces ontario is a province in
canada it happens to be the largest
population uh and these people live in
toronto
now they didn't just live in toronto
during the time of the relationship they
lived
in toronto they lived in muskoka which
is cottage country where he had two
cottages
and they also kept a property down in
florida as well a condo for winters
so this was all tried in ontario because
this is where they spent most of their
time obviously
uh in a situation where the jet-setting
couple kept separate residences and
never lived together full-time so again
never had kids together never got
married never
lived together under the same roof but
she's awarded 53 777
over the next 10 years the men and women
started dating 2001 and parted ways
almost 15 years later
when they met the man was 46 very
wealthy the woman was 38
a former model earning about 60 thousand
dollars per year
each had children from prior
relationships the woman lived only a
few blocks away with primary care of her
two kids
just just stay with me on this okay um
after the first month of dating the man
began to pay the woman home expenses
gave her monthly allowance and was very
generous for her children at this point
she stopped working at her job
this is the first mistake he made if
you're going to maintain separate
residences while you're dating
um she needs to carry on doing what
she's doing see because
one of the things a lot of dudes don't
understand is with
family law and hypergamy women always
date mary up obviously she did a great
job locating somebody that was far
better off than her
she got into the 93rd richest family in
canada
uh to put that in perspective that's 93
out of something like
38 billion people in canada so
lucky for her she was at the eso gas
station that day when she met him
by the way um she also happened to be
dating his younger brother prior to him
which is another interesting piece i
found in case law as well
on the other can lee part which i've got
a few points that i'm not gonna break
which which i am going to break down for
you so
uh those few blocks away after the first
month of dating uh the man began to pay
the woman's home expenses gave her a
monthly allowance it was generous so
right away this guy's simping for her um
this
is where you know having a red pill
awareness around the suction marketplace
and the dynamics that you know
dictate desire attraction and all that
sort of stuff
uh really come into play straight off
the bat this 46 year old
loaded dork just starts simping for this
check quit your job
let me take care of you uh here's an
allowance i'll take care of your kids
uh the extent of which he paid for
things i'm going to show you
when i get to the case law in just a
moment but it was
um without like it was extensive let's
just put it that way
this dude covered everything so over the
course of the relationship the man gave
her access to credit cards a car she had
a mercedes by the way
medical and dental insurance for her and
her kids it doesn't say that here but i
read the case on it was covered there as
well
he bought her seven fur coats and paid
for first storage which needs to be in
cold storage is quite expensive
he paid for cosmetic procedures um i'm
assuming
facelift hair nails eyes
boob job all that kind of stuff he paid
her telephone cell cable internet and
security alarm bills he also paid for
her home insurance guarding and
landscaping
while they spent time together the man
paid for extravagant holidays including
trips on a private jet
they spent most of the summers together
at man's cottage and spent time during
the winters in the mans florida
condominium
at various stages they started their day
with a walk together and had mules
together every night except for when he
was away traveling
yet when they separated the court
described their very divergent positions
on the nature of the relationship
mrs miss clements lisa here
her position is the parties were spouses
and that she was treated as a wife
by mr lattner her evidence is that she
received an engagement ring which she
did which was worth
almost fifty thousand dollars it was a
seven and a half carat uh diamond ring
a wedding band and an eternity band
i'm not sure that he could have done
much more to demonstrate to the courts
that he was in a very serious
relationship with this woman
right she gets an engagement ring a
wedding band and an attorney band
i don't i'm not sure if it mentions it
here in the summary but he also had two
other rings made for her
uh one was um out of an identical
sapphire stone that his mother had and
another
piece of jewelry which seemed pretty
extravagant as well either way
he went to great lengths to
throw shiny objects at her
that are fully aligned with historical
signs and signals of
you know marriage and of course chasing
you know the one
you